[Applause]
passions ran high in Parliament as the
government's illegal migration bill was
debated for the first time
we must control who comes into this
country and the terms under which they
remain here
that's why stopping the boats is my top
priority
but objections came from all corners of
the house does she think the British
public went to see pregnant women and
children detained in Immigration
detention centers I do not believe for a
minute they do but that's what's in this
bill
under the new plan migrants and refugees
arriving on British Shores in small
boats or the back of trucks would be
detained deported and prevented from
ever claiming asylum in Britain
successful Asylum Seekers like colbasia
hausi who fled torture in central Africa
says the proposed law would be a death
sentence for many this bill or this low
wouldn't wouldn't stop me in my journey
in in my goal of safety and and
protection and what probably would would
done is just creating even more social
Journey for me to take and I wouldn't
know exactly would I make it on or not
making
outside Parliament protesters voiced
their opposition to the proposals rights
groups argue the law would break the U.N
convention on refugees and other
commitments the UK has made to Human
Rights many legal challenges lie ahead
and then there are the practical
challenges with a backlog of 160 000
people waiting for an answer on their
Asylum applications detention centers
are already overflowing emergency
accommodation in hotels cost 6 million
dollars a day the question is where will
the new arrivals be detained and how
much will it cost
I'm supporting on Friday Britain signed
a 577 million dollar deal with France to
boost surveillance and policing on
French Shores to intercept more boats
before they leave and break the business
model of the gangs but many want to see
more investment into so-called safe and
legal routes for those fleeing war and
persecution
Beyond Parliament more than 350
businesses Charities unions and legal
groups have condemned the policy on
illegal migration as cruel and
unworkable and they're urging the
government to rethink the policy but
prime minister Rishi sunak says he wants
to push the bill through to become law
hopefully by August Charlie Angela Al
Jazeera London